Hey guys.
Welcome. I am Luka and I head up growth
at Keep up. This also includes developer
relations.
And we have decided to partner with ETH
Global for the Open Agents Hackathon.
This is actually our first Hackathon, so
we are of course especially excited and
equally as nervous. Uh but what this
means is we'll also be on our best
behavior and we'll do our utmost to help
you guys out in any way we can and also
just to be available
uh to answer any sort of questions that
you may have.
The workshop today, the objective of it
at least, is to give you the tools
required to build on top of the
infrastructure that is Keep up. But also
hopefully uh give you guys the
inspiration to do so as well.
I'm going to make sure or I'm going to
try at least to keep this as tight as
possible.
But if you're interested in certain
sections, you can also just head into
the description below
and click on the chapter timestamps to
jump forward to areas that are relevant
uh to what you're looking for.
Let me start here in the hub. We're in
the Keep up platform as we speak and the
hub is a section where you'll be able to
kind of use it as a library of
workflows. Uh the workflows that you see
here are templates that Keep up users
have shared publicly with the community.
So these can actually be copied over to
your own environment um as I'll do with
an example here. Um
let me go ahead and just type in Aave
just to make it simple and I'm going to
use this uh workflow called Aave V3
cross-chain liquidation dashboard.
Going to say use template and what will
happen now is it will duplicate it and
then create it in my own private
environment.
And how to show that as well, you can
see this is private. This is not shared.
And that's exactly actually what the
author of that workflow had done. They
had decided that they wanted to share
this one with the hub, with the rest of
the community to be able to make use of
it.
Now, one thing worth flagging up front
is
well, it matters for the Hackathon is
authors of these workflows, they can
also decide
yeah, to share these workflows to the
hub, but they can also publish uh these
workflows as strategies instead.
And that's a button right next to this
marketplace button where you can list on
agent marketplace.
And what that means is you can then
decide
you know, that this workflow should be a
strategy and you can set a price on it.
So the listed strategy doesn't actually
end up on the hub directly because these
steps are private. We don't want anyone
just to copy the strategy.
Uh but the authors of the strategy can
see it in the earnings window, which is
right here.
And other agents can also discover this
workflow, this strategy and pay to run
it.
And the author will then consequently
earn and you'll have your earnings
listed in this environment.
So consider it be a bit like a
marketplace for on-chain strategies.
And Keep up is the execution layer of
that marketplace.
This is a quite important distinction
just to remember throughout the workshop
today.
Now, if I actually go back to the
workflow example that we have here, I'm
going to go ahead and press run.
What you'll see here is that this
workflow will go ahead and run. So when
an agent calls one of these
or if you run it yourself based on a
cron-based trigger,
Keep up will handle the transaction. It
will
handle retries. It will handle gas. So
if there's exponential increase in gas
cost, then it'll be able to do kind of
retries over specific period of time. It
will also handle a simulation of the
transaction. Uh it will handle the
signing and as you can see here under
the runs, the audit trail, being able to
kind of see every single run
>> [clears throat]
>> and having all their steps listed uh for
you to go ahead and actually be able to
uncover.
Uh I'm showing you this up front because
the rest of the workshop will then have
this as a reference point. So this is
what I mean when I will eventually say,
you know, what Keep up does.
This is it.
And hopefully by the end of the
workshop, you'll understand, you know,
the surface area well enough to decide
what you want to build
um over the next 9 days and also what
qualifies for the price track.
So let's get into it.
Before I explain Keep up in more detail,
let me show you kind of where it fits
into this agent stack.
Uh so at the top, we have these agent
frameworks. We have LangGraph, you know,
Open Claw. Eliza OS could also fit into
here. This is kind of where the
reasoning uh lives.
Then we have the communication MCP from
Anthropic. We all know A2A from Google.
And then we have identity and wallets.
Uh so ERC-804
is a great one
uh kind of being the identity layer, the
reputable layer
uh or registry for agents.
Uh payments, XPRT, MPP, you know,
there's been a lot of around them, too,
uh the past few months. And
finally, we then have the reliable
execution layer kind of where where Keep
up lies. And this is where I mentioned
already previously kind of retries, gas
simulation, SLAs, audit trail, making
sure that you actually have the
transaction land on chain and and that's
of course, as you can see here, the
final box on-chain settlement on EVM
chains, layer twos, etc.
Uh so the gap actually that we see in
most agent stacks today is not so much
the reasoning or the agent framework,
the communication or even actually
wallets now. It's actually that network
congestion
um actually end up killing your agent.
Uh this could be like a gas spike during
uh liquidation and then your transaction
sits in mempool and then somebody else's
lands. Um could also be silent failures
when your agent thinks the action
actually succeeded but didn't.
And then you don't really have any sort
of audit trail or any anything to kind
of prove otherwise.
So Keep up goes ahead and replaces that
whole layer. Uh the agent decides and
Keep up executes. As simple as this. And
if a transaction fails, we retry. If gas
spikes, our engine adapts. You get an
audit trail of every attempt, every
revert reason, every gas price used. And
also have the whole thing SLA backed.
So that's the layer. Now, let me tell
you a little bit about the team behind
Keep up. Uh we already established that
Keep up is the reliable execution layer
for the on-chain economy. Uh but we
haven't really spoken much about the
team. Uh the team behind Keep up are all
Maker X Maker DevOps engineers also
known as, well, Sky Protocol now.
Uh we're also a globally distributed
team, so we'll also be able to help you
guys through throughout all times during
during this Hackathon. Uh we've been
running production layer keepers uh for
the past 7 years, so we've been doing
this
uh way before like the whole term agent
infrastructure was even a category. Um
for you as a hacker, uh what that means
is simple. Keep up is the default
execution layer for agents operating on
chain and we want you to help us make it
even more of a default. Uh so we handle
the parts that are hard to get right
and catastrophic if you don't. Um worth
naming what Keep up is and isn't. It can
be used, as you can see, in the platform
app.keepup.com.
It can be used as a, you know, regular
visual um workflow builder similar to
kind of how you would use N8N for
on-chain ops.
Uh and plenty of users actually already
use it as is today and I highly
recommend that you also play around with
it in the same way. There's definitely a
lot of use cases and as we've already
uncovered, templates in the hub that you
can make use of.
Um but we want to actually think of the
long term and that's where we're
pointing you guys towards and that is
the frame of this Hackathon. Consider
um this sort of as the infrastructure
that agents call programmatically.
Uh the same way TurnKey is for wallets
or Alchemy is for RPC, a component in
this larger stack. And that's the
direction that the Hackathon will be
focused on.
Very quickly, before we get into the
code, uh three places that I recommend
bookmarking include uh one,
the Keep up channel in the ETH Global
Discord. We'll be there, you know, 24/7.
We have a globally distributed team, so
we'll answer no matter the time. Uh two,
uh the Keep up Discord community. We
already have lots of material there uh
that you can make use of. And three,
probably the most important is our
docs.keepup page.
Um to make it all easier, we created
this link tree here that you can make
use of. So you can actually just
bookmark that. That might make it a
little bit easier. And that's just found
at keepup.com/links.
The primary interface is the MCP server,
which is live today. If you prefer to
write scripts from your terminal, then
uh CLI server integration is also
available.
Uh we also have XPRT and MPP
compatibilities if in case you want to
build a agent that is paying on chain.
Uh quick note on wallets. If your agent
needs a wallet for testing, we'd
recommend using Agent Cash to give your
agent a wallet. Uh this is only for
testing purposes and we're not of course
not responsible for Agent Cash security,
but it's easy and fast to get up and
running.
Um let's head over to the documentation
pages here.
And you can always use the search
function in top right corner and I'm
just going to type in MCP. The MCP setup
is is very straightforward. You can find
all the instructions needed here and if
you run into any questions, again, we're
available. Reach out to us. But once the
MCP server is connected, uh the agent
sees the full tools uh surface.
And you'll see type schemers. So, if
you're using Eliza OS, Agent here,
LangChain, or whatever, anything that
basically speaks MCP, uh the tools will
show up natively.
Uh I want to give you guys like kind of
a fast mental model of the surface. So,
let me just switch scenes here.
And pull up Claude.
There it is.
And
what you see here is uh the Keeper Hub
MCP server connected to my Claude
instance.
And I can go ahead and see all the
different schemers that are available.
There are basically two types of
interactions. We have direct execution,
which is when an agent calls an execute
protocol action or an execute contract
call, and then
goes ahead and lands that transaction.
Retries, gas, SIM, all handled, you
know, users kind of like reactive flows.
Uh and then we also have workflows. And
this is a bit different from direct
execution. Instead, now an agent calls
create workflow or AI generate workflow,
and it sends over trigger, conditions,
and actions. Uh Keeper Hub then runs it
continuously, uh and you can use this
for like kind of recurring strategy,
monitoring, anything that should, you
know, keep running
uh when the agent is asleep.
Um under both shapes, uh you have like
the same primitives. So, triggers, like
schedule, webhook, uh on-chain events,
uh condition nodes, and then action
nodes.
And under the action nodes, you'd have
every action that you'd expect, like
ERC-20 transfers, protocol-specific
calls. I showed you the native ones
earlier. So, you know, Aave, Sky,
Compound, etc., etc. And then, of
course, any like if you have like
anything arbitrary, you can use like
execute contract call
uh for that.
Uh two things to internalize for the
hackathon.
Um
One,
this surface is pluggable. Uh so,
protocols you care about that aren't
first class yet, that's a plugin.
Frameworks that don't speak Keeper Hub
clearly yet or cleanly yet, that's a
wrapper.
And then, of course, you know, mis-
missing developer primitives, that's a
contribution.
And then, two, when you hear me say
workflow,
I mean uh the artifact that Keeper Hub
actually runs. So, I don't mean
something you build as a part of your
hackathon project. Uh you'll handle us
the integrations and features in Keeper
Hub actually runs uh the workflows.
Uh so, yeah, we're we're getting there
slowly and steadily.
Quick demo so that I can actually show
you guys this in motion. I'm going to
use Claude here with the Keeper Hub MCP
server connected. The same logic applies
if you were to use an autonomous agent,
basically anything that speaks MCP.
Uh the use case that I'm going to use is
an agent watches an ERC
uh 4626 vault and deposits idle USDC
from a treasury wallet whenever
utilization drops a threshold. So, I'm
going to go ahead and just type in the
intent and actually I'll paste it in
because I have it copied. And what will
happen here is when I press let's go, we
open up the
uh thread here, then Claude uses the MCP
tools that I showed earlier, and we
watch a workflow show up in Keeper Hub.
Obviously, you can see here it will need
a few details that I didn't share um
ahead of this, and it will take me
through it. Obviously, you know, first
one first sort of things first, you
know, which protocol is this for? Uh
Aave V3 I didn't specify, and then I
wanted this run on Ethereum mainnet, and
I want them to use placeholders uh for
the treasury wallet.
Uh now what will happen is this agent
calls the AI generate workflow tool and
then the create workflow tool, and
workflows will then render in the Keeper
Hub canvas with cron triggers, condition
nodes, approval node, deposit nodes, and
and then also Discord uh notification
node. But, let's skip this section was
instead of just waiting around, and
we'll jump directly into the app.
All right, we're back in the app now.
And as you can see, we have this nice
little nifty workflow created. Uh this
is a cron-based workflow
uh that runs on a schedule every hour.
Uh we have a condition here that checks
the vault utilization from here, which
is a code-based node.
And then we have approval for the ERC uh
4626 contract, uh a
uh deposit action, and of course, then a
Discord notification here once
completed.
Uh you might have noticed when I was
clicking through these that we have
placeholder addresses
uh for your treasury wallet, uh and this
is just for the sake of the demo. So,
obviously, you know, this would be
listed with real addresses instead.
And
as
you know, all of this took about 40
seconds from, yeah, the intention to
actually having a live workflow.
And I would say that there's probably
two things that you want to take away
from it. You might take away more
things, but two main ones is that first,
you know, this is what the Keeper Hub
user experience is today. This is your
baseline. Secondly, uh every node here,
every graph, every action type, every
protocol integration, every framework
connection, is something we've built, uh
which brings us to actually what we
would love to see from you guys.
All right, 9 days, and here's what we
hope to see.
Uh we're not looking for agents that use
Keeper Hub as a black spot uh or black
box per se. Uh we're looking for
contributions to Keeper Hub itself.
Uh so, things we can merge, adopt, uh or
ship to every Keeper Hub user after May
3rd. Um three directions that you can
take inspiration from. Um a new protocol
or chain integration. So, this is
potentially, I would say, the biggest
bucket because there's so many different
options here. But, pick pick a
potentially a protocol that we don't
support as a first class integration
yet,
uh or improve an existing one. It could
be a lending market, a purpose-driven
liquid staking protocol bridge, a risk
staking primitive. Yeah, there's lots of
different ones. Uh we already support
lots, so
take inspiration from that and see what
there is. Build a plugin, you know,
workflow nodes for its core operations.
Then there's also the second direction
that you could also take, framework
integrations.
Uh here think about like, you know, Open
Claude, Eliza OS, LangChain, anything in
the agent framework space. And a clean
Keeper Hub plugin tool wrapper for that
framework. Um so, build us using that
framework, uh get Keeper Hub natively uh
without writing well, without having to
write like glue code in between.
>> [snorts]
>> Uh a winning submission here is
something we could actually adopt as an
official integration.
Then, of course, uh there's another wide
bucket, and that is just generally any
sort of new features or developer
tooling inside of Keeper Hub. Uh think
about, you know, workflow nodes that we
don't support yet, better simulation
debugging,
uh observability,
um
testing harnesses, improvements to the
MCP server itself, uh better new user
onboarding. This is always a very big
one, UX and in Web3, uh everyone's
kryptonite. Uh but like let's say if
you've hit a friction point in using
Keeper Hub yourself this week, uh that
friction point can actually go ahead and
be a contribution opportunity.
Um yeah, and maybe one uh specific
callout inside this bucket uh could also
be a great fit for this hackathon is
at the start of this video, I showed you
a published workflow
in the hub, but then also I showed you
listing a strategy with a price
attached. So, a clean contribution here
could also be wiring that up to the open
agent economy, uh like wrap a published
workflow in an ERC
uh 804 registration so that any agent on
that network can discover it, expose
that call behind like XPRL 2 or IPP as a
payment rail, uh and then make sure that
you post reputation back on chain that
after every run. Uh and then all of a
sudden, you kind of have Keeper Hub as
your sort of evidence layer, and you
know, that agent can be found anywhere
um to pay and actually go ahead and
execute uh said strategy. So, that's
also a potential project that you, you
know, we would want to see.
Uh but again, I don't want to put too
many sort of restrictions. You know, we
are quite open-ended here, and that's
also why I have a prize page open.
Uh where you can see everything broken
down. But, if you're in doubt as well,
feel free to reach out to us. I've
mentioned a few times now, but we'll be
in the ETHGlobal Discord channel, we'll
be in our own channel,
we'll be in Telegram,
X, wherever you want to write to us.
Uh we'll be there all 9 days.
And let me also wrap up maybe by
apologizing. At the start of this video,
I said I'll be super tight and keep this
as short as possible. Well, I kind of
tried to do that, but I've already
broken that promise, so apologies. But,
if you did make it this far, uh thank
you very much for staying for the ride.
I hope this was useful. And if you have,
again, I'll say it one final time, if
you do have any questions or anything
that wasn't answered, you know, reach
out to us before the hackathon even
starts or during the hackathon, whenever
you're watching this video. But, um
thank you all, and best of luck to
everyone building, and I really
appreciate you guys, you know,
contributing and taking time out of your
day to do this.